这个世界是可以做闭的
而且正大光明的作弊
这条视频的内容会很长
到底有多长
我也不知道你没打超早了
聊到哪儿算哪
但肯定会非常长
数据无所谓
因为我随时可能会把他杀了
先说一下
作弊这件事情对我来说印象最深刻的或者一样最大的
应该是两千千左右
我在北达旁庭
当时在北达旁庭的人特别多
当时全在那个六洋中
八个附近
住很多人
很多人都在旁庭
你们知道我当时的感受是什么
我这不是做弊吗
你就不需要
你不需要考试
你不需要考得多好
对吧
或者你本来就考了个三本
你不愿意去
你就直接到北达来旁庭吗对吧
违的差别其实就是没有形容这
就该学啥都能学到
而且这个城市呢
你也能就是到失业也开货了
这是当时
我第一次感受到
做弊
这次是可以做弊的而且对人生有很大的影响
那么我来讲第二个做弊
先讲一下故事吧
大概是20
一年还是一二年
具体时间我记不太清楚的
因为当时我是做软件公司吗
我跟那时候有一个好习惯
就是
我认识技术也好
还是过来经验也好
就遇到问题会总结
总结出来就发出来
发出来以后的话呢
可是一些媒体就是自媒体吗
当时有此理体
好的人也复落的
不像现在这么多
但是技术权的里面还是就在民企的
然后就有一个大汉影
当时邀请我去做分享
当时大汉一下来有一千多人
没有一千五百人
一千多人
套成一千五百人
要先我去做分享
在国家会有中心
当时是又尽章又尽分
但是我还是同意了
当时还有两个月的时间吗
两个月的时间
我去做准备
回来以后
真的是滑了一个离拜的时间
反正真的做了个准备
然后呢
周末的时候
要请继织劝那边的几个好朋友
一块吃饭
本来我们也在一块吃饭
然后我非常正式的
就和大家聊一个主题
平时没有这么正式
但是我们在一起肯定会聊一些记录的东西嘛
就那天比我正式
也没跟他说过去做一件事
我做分享
就是很正式的
大家聊了一个主题
大概聊了差不多一个设计吧
大家有很多反馈
我没告诉他们我去参加那个会啊
然后来以后从军整理又滑了一个离拜的时间
当时车不开飞车拍飞有很多房间
然后在客户咖啡的一个房间里面
大概有十几个人二十人吧
然后我又做了个分享
两个有时我去当时还不让你把
还有很准拍照
他不是正式的
他就是随机的
大家这个随机是我有一的随机啊
然后又做了个分享
然后还有很准反馈
然后在这个当时认台上有发
发了一些这个信息
又做了一些新压分享
大概几十人
就是每周我都会做一次分享
几十人几十人几十人在问一个分享
结果那场大会的时候我去了
就是延江号到没有屁肯定的没有
就上台
分享两个要是
整个会以完了以后
大家会有那个投票吗
最喜欢的老师
就我那是最多的
特别舒快的
那从此以后的话
就是好多人就要请很多公司就要请我去他们
公司去做分享吗
那个
仇老
也也正常了
我是不是
当然那个大会的平价
最后的平价
学那平价我是最好的
那我是不是水平最高的
肯定不是
差别的哪儿
就是人家可能只花了两个小时
就是为这个大会的分享做了两个小时
对吧
这个准备
我做了两个绝的准备
那么
很多人说是不是
那你的技术不行
对吧
各位不是这样的
如果你有时间你去
尝射一下
如果你能够集中清理
认真做一件事的话
持续短时间
你会和别人不一样
所以我现在就有一个很好的习惯
每年
一定会选择一个技术方向
一年的时间专注他
一年之后你会和别人
就不一样的
而且的话
就这次把那以后
他利用了干干
就很快的
利用了干干
一千多人都知道我了
然后给我带了很大的这种
这个收益
我在说什么
各位
就是
这个世界
是以你做的最成功的那一次
然后来评价你的
这一点对我的帮助特别大
特别大
为什么
给大家几个小例子吧
其实这个事情之前是困扰我的
彻的又在院
因为之前没准备
讲到达说达
就这个事就是之前是困扰我的
就是我们当时就
80后有一帮做得比较好的人
就是其创业的比较好的
我记得当时有理想
就现在的这个理想公司的理想
然后有某看看
现在这个人已经不在了
还有带制靠
当时就是报道80后
我当时觉得压力
人家把灵后做成这个样子
对吧
就真的很气那
但是后来的话
有一天想通了
就是
这个世界是与你判定的最够风来电影影影的
所以很多人二岁的时候
他去到成就了
你四岁还没有去到成就
但不要你四岁开掉了你居座
所以你可以在六岁的时候
或者七岁的时候去到成就
为什么
因为这个世界是
你去到最够风来电影影影影影影影影影的
当然我现在
思想又更建立一步
好 这个扯对待院咱们再说过来
就是我前一两天
这些也把这个事说过了
我说各位一个事的话
就是一条视频没排好
你可以反负排反负排
一篇文章没有洁好
你可以反负洁
反负洁反负洁
对吧
然后这个世界是一做的最好的那一次
来讲另一的
我谅稀点点排的到视频
结会有刚进了
就说
高考啊
对吧
你有一次没高考
你还有机会吗
对吧
你创业呀
你一次吁倒了
你还有机会吗
我告诉你我和你们
你们最大的不同是什么
我觉得这也是算是个作弊呀
就是很多人把自己限制住了
自己给自己造活着弄的
我呢
是挑对手的
就是我现在基本上不做公平角度
如果是另一个国益
我不做公平角度什么意思
就是我自己会阻动法器战斗
法器什么战斗是我来决定的
什么意思呢
我不打强的
就是平时联系的时候我会高手
逃招
真正角度的时候我从不和高招角度
谁弱我打谁
各位能力要的意思吗
就是比如说市面上谁的东西谁的产品做得好
我能不能做得过他
我做不过他做得过做不过不打了
那我在市面上看谁做得不好
那就那个做得不好
这个领域其他人做好跑
都做得不好我打这个领域
专挑软事件
就创业也好做生也好
专挑软事件能打得过谁
就打谁
而且刚才就不跟你发起什么
咱俩绝度我开什么玩笑
透息
各位你听懂了吗
就是我这时候我和你的不同了
我会专门挑
在那个领域发力
跟谁打
什么时候打
我说了算
而且透息
这是一个
当然还有另外一种的话
那就是他不是领域的
就这个市场很大
只要你能做好
就一定能获得好的收益
我没可以做这样的事情
那就可以不断的做反复做做
比如说
举个例子啊
比如说一本书
举个例子
这本书
你只要写得好
对吧那你就一定会有收益
那你会发现你就可以
反复做持续做
一直写一直写
直到把这个
这个东西做好你就能获得收益
所以各位想象一下
这个世界上有很多事情是你可以自己决定
发起
我要做什么样的事情的
而且这个世界上有很多重不过益
你不用想的一次做好
你可以反复做反复做反复实验
然后你只要最后有一次做好了
这个世界就会将来你
所以各位如果你们看我的视频
就可以发现一个特别有意思的事情
就是有些事我说过了
过上一段时间我还会说
对吧就比如说这条视频我再讲做必须对吧
我还会说还会说说的好吗
我觉得我好
也不需要好
影响我连准备都不太准备
但是可能过上几年
你们会突然看到我的一个作弊或者做的一个事
怎么四成相时我什么时候说
对吧
都是我最后的那个结果
我现在不过是一次爹带
然后你想想在以后说
你找一找你翻一翻
你可能找不着了
为什么
因为当有一件事情我做得很好的时候
我会把以前所有做的操控
全部抹掉